and we are back from our piss break why
did you just say that because because
it's kept in this time so they they knew
that uh we were having a picture there
was like at least an ad in between that
or something you know
just don't break it otherwise would be
very old no
we're either coming back from an ad
break or a piss break or a
who knows but yeah uh as god said we
almost died uh not really and but not
really it's it's no i mean it's it's a
youtuber we almost died like yeah under
certain circumstances i'm sure we could
have died but it felt like i was dying
yeah that's for sure but uh yeah so you
guys probably saw on our social medias
uh that if you don't follow us on
twitter yes please follow us all on
twitter and trash days as well but uh we
posted a couple of photos of us going
camping and uh so many people thought
they were like yeah can't explain comics
no it's not about it it's not
it's it's it's not a bad idea but we do
you know we do like to hang out as mates
as well they're they're thought that
sometimes we just hang out with our
cameras
holy [ __ ] are we allowed to do that is
that leaving no we didn't take pictures
we did
like come on that's not part of my
contract cameras
for the second channel but i was having
too much fun where i was like [ __ ] it
yeah maybe not vlog what i was just
getting smashed yeah yeah exactly
but uh
yeah so basically uh nabi who uh works
behind the camera as well as a bunch of
his friends and three of us we went
camping to mount fuji and it was [ __ ]
awesome
it was awesome until it was awesome
until we almost died until we had to
sleep and uh
it is uh the first time i've been
camping in these kind of weather
situations same um so it was the first
time so camping in england right the
most you got to [ __ ] worry about is
some mild rain a lot of times it's like
a mild annoyance i've kept in the winter
before i think in the uk yeah i'm pretty
sure but it wasn't that cold yeah right
like how how cold does it get in the uk
in the winter though it depends where
you are in the uk because it's like a
lot of places snow right in the uk yeah
yeah snow is fine though
that's all right sounds all right yeah
snow isn't that cold i mean it was it
was
it wasn't even snowing where we were
pretty [ __ ] hot everything was frozen
yeah yeah frozen is like worse than cold
yeah yeah that's like when the grass is
frozen it's like way colder because when
the snow compact doesn't feel as cold
right yeah why
but we basically went to this place
called para which uh if you've watched
eurocamp is is the place where they're
going is it is that legitimate actual
europe that's actually where they went
it's actually yeah it's like the actual
location they went
which is why there's so many euro camp
references they [ __ ] lie to me they
[ __ ] lie to me they made it look
comfy they made it look [ __ ] what's
comfy about negative five degrees
weather trying to sleep in a [ __ ]
tent there was nothing comfy about that
let me give you the uh the lowdown yeah
please please please please do all right
first of all this this it began in a
group chat right yeah camping trip we're
like we're gonna do a camping trip group
chat i'm checking out immediately i'm
that one friend that doesn't read the
group chat i don't look at it whatever
if you want something from me message me
i don't open group chats because the
moment i see 20
messages i'm like
all right peace
i'm not i'm not reading twitter give me
your cliff notes yeah i'm like someone
just tell me yeah and then i'm sorry for
your loss but i'm not reading that
i don't know about you boys it's my my
pov yeah it's like a few days before and
i'm like oh yeah [ __ ] i don't have
anything
i realized i didn't have anything i was
like oh yeah i have camping stuff
thinking back to like the uk i'm like
yeah i i don't have camping stuff
right yeah i thought i had a sleeping
bag i did not have a sleeping bag okay
yeah and i didn't bring a chair i forgot
about that so i had to buy a chair last
minute so i wanted amazon panicking me
like
two days before because uh they told me
to buy stuff because i was like oh [ __ ]
i didn't buy storage so i started
looking and um
there was only one sleeping bag that was
available to be delivered in time before
i left i could have gone to a store i
don't want to go to a store yeah so i
was like i'll get one of amazon i'm lazy
i bought a chair too and it arrived the
chair was very heavy very big i was like
[ __ ] to be fair was worth though right
yeah the chair the chair came in i think
i had the best chair in the end actually
it was this chair
because joey's one had water damage from
like the amount of times he'd like put
it outside yeah this chair is quite
heavy very big i'd say it's not that big
actually that's bigger but it was a
chair where the back was connected to
the legs so when you leaned on the back
the legs popped up and i don't know man
it was so sad it's like a reclining
chair but camping yeah yeah anyway so i
got all the stuff right and i'm like all
right i've been camping a ton before
it's whatever i don't need to buy too
much it's one night one night camping is
like bro i could just do that with like
my clothes i'll just sleep on the grass
it's not a big deal right like i'll be
fine yeah
because i've done that before i've we've
like slept outside with just sleeping
bags we have done that oh yeah yeah yeah
exactly um no tent yeah yeah yeah you've
done that yeah i've done i've done it to
you is that not a big deal i thought it
would be fine if the weather's good
especially
nabby was like oh did you get like a
thermal wear i'm like
i'm not gonna double that what the [ __ ]
it's like i'm can't barely thermal
i'll wear a hoodie bro it's fine mind
you we went like first week in december
so most places in japan it hasn't quite
gotten to like winter weather it
definitely isn't that cold in tokyo okay
here's the thing right and i was he said
that to me and i was like oh look how
cold it's going to be it predicted like
one degree yeah yeah and i was like one
degree is fine if i'm sleeping in my
clothes in a sleeping bag in a tent one
degree is fine if i'm wearing because i
had like a hoodie and a big coat and i
had a long sleeve shirt yeah i'll be
fine i'll be fine i was not fine okay
we're talking about celsius by the way
yes i'll say
celsius for american that's four
lollipops actually uh because you want
to convert that um
sorry i think it's like 36 fahrenheit
it's very full yeah so so i you know
that's what we thought was going to be
so anyway we had a great time right we
got in the car yeah yeah played some
beats we we had a nice car journey
two-hour car journey to fuji you know
it's pretty chill from tokyo and got the
most insane views of mountains oh yeah
it was like clear my god i mean you saw
the pictures the [ __ ] views the
reason we went in winter was because
there's no mist no cloud at all right
it's just a clear picture of mount fuji
and
the every picture i took of mount fuji
actually looks photoshopped oh yeah it's
unfucking we put that green screen to
work
it was
amazing there was no cloud in sight
right yeah it was you know insane
another car there i was getting kind of
toasty i was getting a little bit too
hot i had to see a hoodie off i was the
sun wasn't the sun was out i was like
i was one layering i was like bro this
is going to be easy mode yeah and then
you know if all else failed i would have
beer so if i got super cold at least i
would be moderately drunk and i could
sleep yeah yeah right so i thought that
was also my strategy this is this it
might never matter this is a foolproof
plan yeah nothing could go wrong and
like we we've been camping before zombie
and joe and we weren't going to make the
same mistake uh we bought way too many
beers this time we bought like two
crates beers two two more crates of
beers than we actually needed in the end
um yeah because i thought everyone's
gonna pull their weight yeah i mean yeah
i mean i mean everyone had the same
around the same amount yeah i had them
some people had one oh really one beer
what the [ __ ] from like 72 beers that we
bought that is not pulling your weight
because i i think we all had like maybe
seven i was very drunk yeah it's like
seven or eight beers i'm i'm gonna say
that uh some people i heard weren't able
to sleep during like during the trip
yeah uh because it was so cold and i'm
just saying i did sleep with lit and uh
i had some beers so what can you say
what can you say right what can you say
life hack live we'll go into that pov
later on so we go to the we go to the
nearest supermarket to this uh place we
raid their entire beer stock their bread
stock their sausages [ __ ] the sausages
are so good yeah there's just something
about sausages on a charcoal grill that
just hits me okay
but sausage is the best i don't know why
okay i i'm gonna say uh when we were
buying sausages everyone's just like oh
just buy the original
you're saying just buy the original
flavor you just buy the original flavor
and i pick up the chili cheese flavor
and everyone looks at me such disgust
everyone looks at me with like such
disgust of like gone what are you doing
get your trash taste out of here and
then when we started eating it it it it
was like the sausage that went the
quickest you know everyone has some
everyone loves them i like the other one
[ __ ] you joey that's not what you were
saying earlier no no because i got i was
curious because everyone around me was
like yeah these chili cheese ones are
really good i'm like i bet i had it and
i was like okay it's pretty all right
that is not what you say that wasn't
always had a good sauce i was probably
like what three or four beers in
something i was like super obviously i
was like yes your
you can use that excuse for like you
know drunk trying sausages you think
that you think that holds up in the
court of law with drunk driving no it
doesn't joey it doesn't it does it does
can't believe i would get betrayed by
this because he said it doesn't mean it
was a good decision
i didn't quite kill another person
eating this sausage you killed him you
killed my spirit joey
when i killed my taste buds you killed
you killed my spirit that's all that
matters man
market we take everything we get every
condiment known to me i was glad you
know sometimes people you know when they
buy all the meat and stuff they forget
to buy the continents but arguably we
bought too many condoms
this bougie [ __ ] bought dijon i
didn't i didn't that wasn't me
mustard when we were on a bbq i'm like
bro just get the [ __ ] squiddy
it was like the one in the jar yeah
well there was no knives so i was like
what do you expect just [ __ ] like
we're gonna like get in the [ __ ]
dijon on my hot dog by the way there was
no hot dog buns in because sometimes
they don't have hot dog buns in the
supermarkets in japan so we did the the
joey way of doing it which is folding a
piece of australian
okay it's fine it tasted fine but it
just looked sad it looks sad it
literally does the same thing
actually if anything
tastes the same
i would argue it's better because you
eat less bread therefore you have more
space for sausages
i never finished the entire sausage um
like the hot dog the hot dog ones are so
thick yeah the entire the entire uh hot
dog bun you know because there's always
there's always like more bread needed
than the sausage in it
i can't believe these takes actually i'm
not even i'm not even you know what i'm
both bonds are overrated i am so done
that was such a [ __ ] take i'm not even
gonna i'm not i'm not arguing i'm not
arguing with this what are you talking
about i refuse to start to go down to
the level of clowns i'm not arguing this
okay i'll i'm gonna let that take speak
for itself i'm just gonna say i don't
agree respectfully i disagree guys okay
i think the bread is the perfect amount
anyway
i can't believe you just said that like
yeah
i can't believe this i'm sorry
it's pretty thick right it's like twice
the thickness people who love hot dogs
are dying right now dying in the inside
that's all okay so we spent 400 on on
this food for like nine seven nine eight
eight of us yeah yeah 400 bucks on food
yeah it was good and yeah
oh yeah
it was mostly there was like actually
yeah
we bought it all and we finally started
setting up our camp yeah and getting the
fire going which is the most we had two
fire pits going yeah and then uh we we
bought like two little baby stacks of
like plywood or whatever it was like it
wasn't plywood but it may well be like
two by fours yeah and luckily the stall
there sold a [ __ ] ton of firewood so we
bought a [ __ ] ton of fireworks oh yeah
in japan you have to buy your firewood
you can't just like go into the bush no
no no no no you got to buy your phone
too in most places in uh most campsites
like official ones you can't do that
yeah oh really in europe as well you
can't just start chopping down trees
unless the site says you can but most
people don't do like most people don't
know how to chop down a tree though
but like in australia we don't like go
around you know [ __ ] deforesting or
anything but like you know if you go out
into the bush and you you could be like
deadly yeah you pick up like the dead
bro
and stuff like that you bring it back
like that's problem is though that
branches burn super fast right that's
what you're going to get like
like you know almost rotting wood yeah
so they sold these uh really thick
pieces of oak that were great it was
wonderful we just don't have a fire and
we started barbecuing it's great yeah
that's fantastic so we're happy we were
having a fantastic time it was like a
comfortable temperature as well it was
like probably like you know maybe five
degrees
i think i would say it was even like
warmer than that i was like really like
six maybe six seven degrees what a great
time started cracking open
started enjoying the food it was
brilliant yeah joey laughed at how i had
a hot dog one time or something i
remember you were like what you're like
laughing your ass off how i at this hot
dog one time oh yeah yeah yeah i like
because we were like five or six beers
in and connor was obviously like you
know getting a little bit tipsy and he
took i don't know it just caught my eye
like i just i just looked over and
connor had this hot dog bite and it
looked like the hot dog was trying to
escape out of his mouth because i shoved
half the hot dog
in his mouth
all i heard was this like you know like
the [ __ ] video of the the puffer fish
eating the
carrot
as he was shoving this hot dog he's like
oh
i was like oh my god joey's like pissing
himself because i was like
i was like bending over because there's
a lot of sauce on it because i put i did
the rookie area putting away too much
condiments and i knew the condiments was
going to come out right yeah yeah and
what had happened was that i think i
think i had taken a bite that was so big
that i either committed to putting it
all in my mouth in one go
or if i bit it and stop the condiments
would just go all over me so i bet i
bent forward and just shoved it all in
and won and all the condiments like fell
down hey yo this boy's [ __ ] down a
hot dog i was like
it was just so good man
i don't know what it is for some reason
with hot dogs when it comes to barbecues
like i can eat like two burgers and i'm
like oh [ __ ] yeah hot dogs i'm like
another one another one please i'm like
six and i'm like let's go another hot
dog not a hot dog to be fair those
sausages are really i actually think i
actually prefer hot dogs over burgers
in a barbecue because like in a barbecue
you have one burger and that's that's
enough of me that's enough that's like
to if if we're gonna go with like how
many like courses are structured to me
like the burger is the main course right
but i can eat so much of like the hot
dog around the burger you know you start
off with hot dogs and you have the
burger and then for some reason you can
eat like three more hot dogs sometimes
it's like it's like my stomach is an
infinite hole when it comes to hot dogs
when it comes to hot and we also have
like the skewers as well which we just
got demolished in like five minutes as
well because they were so good and like
yeah what is it about burgers that is
just like on a different scale of like
filling compared to like everything else
we bought i don't know i don't get it i
think it's just because it takes that
much more effort to cook i guess right
because you have to like you have to
like build the burger as well and it's a
lot bigger you know it's it's not just
something it's not just something you
can you know casually pick up off the
grill and just start eating you gotta
you gotta make sure it's like a nice
burger that you like you gotta make sure
the cheese is perfectly toasted the way
you want it to be toasted um we tried to
like butter our bread but like the
butter was so [ __ ] cold that i think
i think it was edo or something who uh
tried to uh put butter put blocks of
butter on the burger bun so it was like
squares of butter on this burger bun
because it was like too cold to be
spread and then he just like chucked it
on the fire just chucked it on the fire
and all the chunks just fell down
and he was adamant that he could
perfectly butter this oh my word i was
watching the entire time i was like what
what did you want to do
i was like what were you expecting he's
just buttering the fire
in my mind when you're at a and you're
barbecuing stuff i'm like i expect the
quality of this burger to not be
as on par as a restaurant yeah i don't
need my my barbecued uh burger buttered
bun i'm like you can just toast but it
wasn't even like the worst idea that
happened during the first it was a good
idea i know you're gonna say this
because because like you know when
you're a few drinks then you do
something that you think is a good idea
and like it works in your mind a genius
so we had we also had eggs right but we
had nowhere to cook the eggs so kind of
like a grill right well yeah we didn't
have pans or anything no no pans we just
had like a grill a mesh grill right uh
so kind of comes up with the idea of uh
trying to to cook this egg on a burger
bun and uh
you know
i really wanted an egg on my burger all
right so what he does is he places the
patty on the grill and then it was the
bun oh sorry the pan so that he places
the bun on the grill and then he cracks
an egg on top of it naturally all the
white of the egg just [ __ ] spills
over yeah
i knew that all that's left is a [ __ ]
yolk and this yolk is like it's like ice
hockey it was just like slippering
around on this thing and he's just like
trying to [ __ ]
control it yeah and then in the end it
uh it spilled over it went in the fire
it was a very sad moment yeah no no i
was saying there's no way you can cook
an egg on a burger bun on a grill that's
just like this there's so many things
that can go wrong and it did go here's
what my thinking was is obviously i was
a few years in but i was i thought that
the flames of the fire were so big
because it was like enveloping the bun
yeah i was like it'll reach the egg
it'll cook the egg yeah it'll do it
it'll do it it's hot enough it'll do it
the entire time as well he was like
galaxy brain galaxy brain watch this
game of moment game of moment i'm just
like you are wasting a perfectly good
egg no i had an eggy bun and it gave the
a good egg flavor to mine there was like
one fifth of the yolk left over
hey it was good it's just me you just
made eggy bread yeah i liked it i liked
it it was good it was good
it's like the world's shittiest french
toast it was amazing i had a great
burger this is what i brought the
aluminium foil yeah everyone used it
because like you are you are so
dedicated to cooking this egg and it was
like watching someone try to [ __ ]
solve that zelda puzzle in breath of the
wild
we know we know how [ __ ] shitty it is
like controlling controlling that puzzle
with like your wiimote or whatever you
guys sit in your comfort of knowing what
works i i am the daring type i tried
something new i wanted to see if i could
get an egg to cook on a burger i knew it
wasn't gonna go well because the whole
ordeal started with connor going watch
this
and you know anything that starts with a
confidence watch this five beers is not
going to go well imagine if it worked
though i'd have been like a [ __ ] i
would have applauded you i would have
been a god amongst men yes i made that
work
that would have been amazing yeah but
you know i mean you know
too close to the sun i tried something
that i shouldn't have
what can i say you know
it was it was
and then you gave up and just like
flipped the burger and then the rest the
egg just went into the fire i wanted to
i was like all right if i can't have the
egg cooked perfectly on the bun i'll at
least have this french toast yeah yeah
to add to it exactly
yeah
it added out of the flavor profile that
i was quite happy